welcome this afternoon to the Yale
quantum Institute I'm Rob told Hoffman
the director
Institute and it's my pleasure this
afternoon to introduce the speaker for
the third of this year's leadpage
lectures so if you've been following
along you know that we're very honored
and privileged to have John Prescott
here giving this series of lectures so
John is the Fineman professor of physics
at Caltech and the director of their
Institute for quantum information in the
matter and John has many accomplishments
early in his career he worked in string
theory and quantum gravity and more and
more these days he's been working in
quantum information now for many decades
and also in the connections that we were
there for yesterday's lecture between
these things so John has received many
awards he's noted for his pedagogy
there's a long list of similar invited
lecture series and so on that he's given
many places and we're very glad to have
him here
john is a member of the National Academy
and also he's contributed really
fundamental things to quantum
information theory together with Daniel
Guzman they had some really seminal
results in the fault-tolerance which is
an important thing that was sort of the
final nail saying theoretically one can
really build eventually large-scale
quantum computers and so welcome again
John and we're looking forward to
today's lecture about space-time and
quantum error correcting colors
well thanks very much Rob it's been
exciting today to be visiting the Yale
quantum Institute where such great
science is being done I'm going to be
talking today about some work I did with
some brilliant postdocs Benny Yoshida
and Fernando pesto skee who were until
recently postdocs at Cal Tech and Daniel
Harlow who's at Harvard and visited Cal
Tech which is what instigated our
collaboration it was a very enjoyable
collaboration and fittingly the author's
names spelled happy now as you've heard
in my previous lectures if we look at
the field of quantum information science
we might take the view that we are in
the early stages of the exploration of a
new frontier of physical science what we
could call the complexity frontier or
entanglement frontier we are developing
and perfecting the tools that we need to
build up complex quantum states highly
entangled States too complex for us to
be able to simulate them with our
digital computers beyond the reach of
most of our theoretical tools for
understanding how these states will
behave how to describe them and that's
going to be important for future
technologies but it's also important in
giving us new ways to explore basic
questions about physics and we can
expect that the ideas that we're
developing about quantum information
processing are going to have a broad
impact on other areas of physics and one
area in which we've been seeing that
happen in the last few years is quantum
field theory and quantum gravity where
there's been a growing realization that
concepts pertaining to quantum
information
like entanglement and quantum computing
and quantum error correction are
relevant to problems that are of
interest to field theorists and quantum
gravity theorists and what I want to
talk about today is a connection between
two important ideas in physics two of
the most amazing ideas really that I've
encountered in my scientific lifetime so
one is the holographic correspondence
holographic duality between bulk space
times and boundaries of space times the
holographic duality it's the best handle
that we have on understanding quantum
gravity non-perturbative lee and the
other is quantum error correction which
is the basis for our confidence that we
will be able to realize scalable quantum
technologies in the not-too-distant
future and I'd like to argue that these
ideas are in fact closely related that
we can think it is fruitful to think of
the holographic correspondence and
quantum gravity as a realization of
quantum error correction and this idea
which we developed in the paper built on
an inspiring early paper earlier paper
by O'Mara dong and Harlow so let me
remind you of some of the things I said
in yesterday's talk about the
holographic correspondence it was a
particularly important for helping us to
understand the issue of what happens to
information that's processed by a black
hole while the Cena in formulating this
correspondence in the 90s really showed
us how to put a black hole in a bottle
in effect the interior the bottle is
what we call the bulk or 80s space and
negatively curved space-time the walls
of the bottle are what we call CFT for
conformal field theory and according to
the correspondence there's an
act relationship between physics living
only on the boundary and evolving
according to some local Hamiltonian of a
quantum field theory without gravity and
the gravitational physics in the bulk
describing in classical limit described
by classical general relativity but also
including quantum correction so the
space-time in the bulk can fluctuate and
evolve
black holes can form and evaporate in
particular and if we think about what
happens to information that enters a
black hole horizon then the black hole
eventually evaporates if we look at it
from the boundary point of view where
there's no gravitation and no black hole
it seems manifest that information is
preserved that the dynamics is
microscopically reversible and nothing
is lost from the universe so at least in
this case which is the situation where
we understand quantum gravity the best
it seems that the formation and
evaporation of a black hole does not
destroy information now that isn't to
say we completely understand what's
going on this correspondent still hasn't
given us a very concrete picture of how
information escapes from inside a black
hole and it's not clear exactly what the
boundary physics is telling us about the
experience of an observer who falls
through the horizon and enters the
interior of the black hole so there's
certainly certainly many open questions
but this has encouraged us to believe
that in the correct theory of quantum
gravity black hole evaporation is a
microscopically irreversible process so
what is this correspondence I've tried
to depict it in this picture in a
rendering in which the bulk space-time
is two plus one dimensional so there's a
two dimensional slice through the bulk
and to indicate the negative curvature
I've represented that two-dimensional
disc as a Poincare a disc the colored
regions
in the picture are geometrically the
same size but they appear to be smaller
and smaller as you get closer and closer
to the boundary that's a way of
depicting that negative curvature and
according to the correspondence there's
an exact relationship between the states
and the observables in the bulk and on
the boundary so there's a one-to-one
mapping of States to States and
observables to observables between the
two descriptions and in the
correspondence the way we usually use it
and think about it relates weakly
coupled gravity which is nearly
classical relativity but with some small
quantum Corrections to the ball in the
bulk to a very strongly couple field
theory without gravity on the boundary
and the dictionary that relates the two
descriptions is very complex so in
particular the observables that would be
potentially measurable by observers in
the bulk who are working locally the
local observables those local
observables deep inside the bulk
appeared to be very non-local when
rendered in the boundary description now
one way of thinking about the extra
dimension in the vault relative to the
boundary is that you can view it as a
scale in the boundary Theory the
boundary theory is a conformal field
theory it's scale invariant and as we go
deeper and deeper into the bulk that
corresponds to viewing the boundary
physics at longer and longer distance
scales or at lower and lower energy but
it's still a highly non-trivial thing
that the bulk physics would look
essentially strictly local in the limit
of semi classical gravity even on scales
which are short compared to the
curvature scale of this ABS geometry and
what the recent developments seem to be
teaching us about this correspondence is
that we can think of the geometry in the
bulk as arising from or being
describable by
entanglement in the boundary theory and
that's mostly what I want to talk about
how we can think about geometry of
space-time as an emergent property
related to quantum entanglement but let
me say a little bit about quantum error
correction because I'm going to make you
so the idea of a quantum error
correcting code in this construction and
I just for one slide want to explain the
basic idea of how quantum error
correction is supposed to work to
control errors in a quantum system so
let's imagine we have some quantum
system let's say it's n qubits and it
interacts with the environment with the
outside world in some way and I can
describe up that by some unitary
transformation that acts on the system
and the environment and without loss of
generality I can expand the action on
the system in terms of some complete set
of operators that act on the system
those are the EAS in this picture where
each one of those operators is
associated with some corresponding
corresponding state of the environment
but I'm not assuming here that the
states of the environment is rather bad
notation actually are necessarily
mutually orthogonal or normalized so
there's no less most loss of generality
and what I've written down this could
describe either decoherence if states of
the environment are mutually orthogonal
so the system becomes entangled with the
environment
it could also describe unitary errors
unitary transformations acting on the
system due to imperfect control of the
system if all the states of the
environment were actually in the same
state and then our task is to reverse
the damage to undo this effect of the
noise on the system which might have
caused it to become entangled with the
environment and we can't really undo the
fact that the environment became
entangled with something because we
don't control the environment but what
we can do is transform the entanglement
of the environment with the system into
tangle meant of the environment with
some and silho which we control in our
laboratory and then that insula can be
discarded and refreshed and used again
in future rounds of error correction so
this process is a kind of refrigeration
if you like due to the noise entropy
leaks into the system it heats up and we
want to flush the entropy out and that's
what the error correction procedure does
if I want to eventually clear the insula
and reuse it I have to erase it
that's a thermodynamically irreversible
process for that I would have to pay a
power bill but in doing so I can remove
the entropy from the system and clean it
up and performing many rounds of error
correction maintain it in some delicate
superposition state for a long time now
this isn't going to work for arbitrary
errors acting on the system the errors
have to be of a restricted type for it
to work what we usually suppose is that
the noise is fairly weak and weakly
correlated so that in this expansion /
error operators the ones that occur with
significant amplitude are ones of low
weight which act on a small fraction of
all the qubits among the end and that's
what would happen for weak weakly
correlated noise so we want to be able
to reverse errors of that type but we
won't be able to do that for arbitrary
states of our n-cubed system we can only
get it to work for some protected
subspace which has to be cleverly chosen
so that the error operators act
trivially on that subspace and so we can
undo the damage and so that's a quantum
code a quantum error correcting code
which has been chosen so that the errors
are reversible if there are sufficiently
low weight and what I want to describe
to you is a construction of a new class
of quantum codes we call them
holographic quantum codes which realize
some of the features of the holographic
course
this and which I think give us some
insights into the nature of that
correspondence so you can think of this
as a kind of tensor Network realization
of the holographic principle so by that
I mean we can imagine tiling a
negatively curved space with polygons
and associating with each of those
polygons some tensor and that tensor has
two kinds of indices some dangling
indices which we can think of as the
degrees of freedom on which bulk
operators act and also some internal
indices which are contracted with the
indices of neighboring tensors and so we
have an addition uncontracted indices
all the way on the boundary and we want
to think of those uncontracted boundary
indices as the physical variables of
some boundary theory and the dangling
indices in the bulk as the physical
variables of the bulk theory and what
this tensor network actually defines as
well discussed is an embedding of the
bulk degrees of freedom in the boundary
hilbert space which is a kind of quantum
error correcting code which is well
protected against a certain class of
errors so the virtue of this type of
description is it's quite concrete we
can describe the dictionary quite
explicitly we can compute properties of
the code but it's only intended to be
kind of a toy model of holography it's
not really the real thing it's something
that we need to flesh out further to
make a richer connection between quantum
error correcting codes and the
holographic correspondence now I should
emphasize that this dictionary is not
complete I said that there was a
one-to-one correspondence between the
bulk theory and the boundary theory but
that's not what I just described I
described an embedding of the bulk
Hilbert space as some subspace in the
boundary Hilbert space so we we're not
taking into account
all of the observables all of the
degrees of freedom of the bulk the way
to think about it is that we're
interested in how to describe in the
bulk the operators which when acting on
the boundary theory map the low energy
states to low energy states this code
space corresponding to the bulk is
appropriate for describing smooth
perturbations of the ad S geometry and
that corresponds on the boundary to
operators that map states of low energy
to other states of low energy and if I
wanted to include higher energy states
I'd have to go beyond the code space
that we're talking about and I'll come
back to that later so let's think a
little bit about why it should be that
local operators in the bulk in this
correspondence correspond to very non
local operators on the boundary one way
of thinking about it is this that we can
imagine acting deep inside the bulk
space-time with some local operator and
the bulk Theory obeys at least to a very
good approximation relative relativistic
causality so the effects of that bulk
operator will not be felt outside the
future light cone of the event where
that local operator was applied in the
ball and that light cone reaches the
boundary only at a much later time so at
the time that we applied the local
operator the effects of it are not at
least easily visible on the boundary and
so what's happening is that when that
bulk operator is applied on a particular
spatial slice there is some
corresponding operator being applied on
the boundary but it's extremely
non-local its effects can't be observed
by local observers who are confined to a
small portion of the boundary at least
not right away but as the system on the
boundary continues to evolve
eventually the effects of that very
non-local operator become local
observable and that corresponds to the
time in which this light cone reaches
the boundary but at the time that the
local operator is first applied there's
some very non-local operator on the
boundary that it corresponds to and we'd
like to understand that correspondence
better and I'm going to tell you a few
things in the next few slides about this
ad s CF T correspondence because we
would like to see how these features are
realized in the codes that I'm going to
construct so in this slide there's a lot
of information maybe that we don't
necessarily need but the upshot is this
that suppose I consider some part of the
boundary I called it region a here along
the boundary and some point in the ball
and I'd like to know whether the
operator applied to that point X in the
ball can be reconstructed on region a on
the boundary and from what we know about
the correspondence we can make the
following statement that associated with
region a if I look at the two endpoints
of the region there's some shortest path
the geodesic through the bulk that
connects together those endpoints and
because of the negative curvature that
shortest path dips deep inside the bulk
because that's the fastest way to get to
the other end of a to go through the
bulk rather than along the boundary and
the region that i've colored in green
between a and this geodesic is called
the causal wedge of region a and if the
point X lies in that causal edge of a
then the operator in the bulk applied at
X can be reconstructed in the Boundary
Theory on region a and the way one shows
this just so you know is that we can
imagine propagating the
classical field equations in the bulk if
we use the leading classical
approximation in the ball those field
equations are causal in the radial
direction and so if I want to know
whether boundary data on a is sufficient
to tell me about the effect of the
operator plate applied tax the question
is whether a contains the past light
cone of X but where the past is now
defined radially on the boundary and so
there's some region here which provides
sufficient data to determine X on the
boundary it's not all on one time slice
but then we can use the Heisenberg
equations of motion on the boundary to
squeeze it down to the time slice and
that means that we can reconstruct this
operator just on the boundary if X is in
the causal wedge of a now you can see
that this is an ambiguous reconstruction
on the boundary because there are lots
of ways in which I could choose the
causal wedge for a point X in the ball
so for example suppose that I divide the
boundary up into three regions which
I've called a B and C and consider some
point deep inside the ball now that
point is in the causal wedge of the
union of a and B and it's in the causal
wedge of the union of B and C and also
the union of a and C so according to
what I just told you about
reconstruction this bulk operator Phi it
should be possible to reconstruct that
on the boundary as an operator which is
supported only on a B and that means it
would commute with any operator that
supported on region C but likewise I can
reconstruct it on BC which means it
commutes with any operator localized on
a and I can reconstruct it on AC which
means it must commute with any local
operator supported in B
but that seems to mean that it commutes
with all the local operators on the
boundary but that doesn't really make
sense because the field algebra of the
theory on the boundary is irreducible
and the only thing that commutes with
all the local operators is the identity
so that would mean the only operator we
can reconstruct on the boundary on the
identity is the identity and that that
can't be right
so this was this puzzle was discussed in
this earlier paper by ole Mary dong and
Harlow and their proposal was that in
fact these three different
reconstructions on a B BC and AC really
are physically different operators in
the boundary theory so in what sense can
we say that there are reconstructions
are the same bulk operator well they act
on the code space in the same way
there's some code subspace of the
boundary theory but there are many ways
of physically representing an operator
acting on the boundary degrees of
freedom that acts on the code subspace
in a prescribed way and these different
reconstructions correspond to physically
different operators on the boundary but
they act on the code space in the same
way and what we wanted to do was to
construct codes that realize this idea
concretely so another thing you should
know about as I tell you about the
properties of the code is the
distinction between what's called the
entanglement wedge and the causal wedge
you can you can understand that
distinction in this example so consider
a boundary region which has two
connected components which I've called
a1 and a2 and so a1 has some causal
wedge colored in blue here and a2 has a
causal wedge but suppose regions a1 and
a2 are sufficiently large that if I
tried to find the minimum length
geodesics that connect together the four
end points of a1 and a2 the shortest way
of doing so connects the endpoint of a1
with an end point of a 2 here and here
and then the causal wedge is distinct
from the entanglement wedge is the
region contained between
a 1 and a 2 on the boundary and these
two minimal geodesics in the ball so
that's the region colored in blue here
on the right hand side the entanglement
wedge is bigger than the causal wedge in
this case and the ADEs CFT folklore is
that if a point lies in the entanglement
wedge of the union of a1 and a2 then it
should be possible to reconstruct that
operator on the union of a1 and a2 ok
well that doesn't follow just from the
construction that we already talked
about which only guarantees that we can
reconstruct an operator in the causal
wedge of a1 on a1 and in the causal
wedge of a2 on a2 so we'd like to
understand how this can be true of
holography in our code construction this
is only for hyperbolic space right well
so how do we go beyond hyperbolic space
it's it's much harder and there are
ideas about how to do holography for de
sitter space for example and
asymptotically flat spaces which I'm not
really going to talk about it's not
nearly as well understood and the code
construction that I'm going to discuss
really only applies to the hyperbolic
case the easiest case incidentally if
you'd like to know why people say that
we should be able to reconstruct
operators in the entanglement wedge of a
disconnected region that I should be
able to reconstruct a local operator
here on the Union of a1 and a2 for
example one reason people say that is
because we can ask what are the effects
of entangling degrees of freedom in the
bulk on the entanglement on the boundary
and there are convincing arguments that
if I consider 2 degrees of freedom in
the bulk one inside the entanglement
wedge and one outside that if I entangle
those two that
contribute to the entanglement on the
boundary between a the union of a1 and
a2 and the complementary region outside
the union of a1 and a2 and that really
only makes sense if I can define
operators which are supported on a and
on its complement which can detect that
entanglement between a and its
complement so operationally in order for
that bulk entanglement to have a
sensible interpretation we should be
able to reconstruct local operators in
the entanglement which and we'd like to
understand why that's so I mentioned
yesterday the holographic entanglement
entropy the correspondence between
entanglement on the boundary and
geometry in the bulk it goes like this I
can consider some region on the boundary
some connected region in this case and I
could ask for the state on the boundary
how entangled is region a with the
complementary region that can be
quantified by the entropy of a if I
trace out the complementary region I get
some density operator for a which in
general will be mixed if a and its
complement are entangled and the greater
the entanglement the higher the entropy
of that density operator it's a measure
of how much information is missing to an
observer on a because it resides in the
correlation between a and its complement
and in order to describe that
entanglement geometrically I consider
the geodesic in the bulk which connects
the endpoints of region a and Express
the length of that geodesic in the
suitable gravitational units and that's
the entropy or in higher dimensions
where let's say when the bulk is has a
three-dimensional spatial slice this
would be a surface of minimal area
connecting together the boundary points
of region a but through the bulk and the
relationship between the area of that
minimal surface and the entropy is
exactly the relation
ship between entropy and area for a
black hole relating the entropy of the
black hole to the area of its event
horizon so because of the hyperbolic
geometry this minimum length geodesic or
minimal surface will want to dive deep
into the ball he wants to cross the
minimal number of colored regions and
the way to do that is not to follow the
geometry near the surface but to dive
deep inside the bulk okay so I'm going
to explain how we construct these codes
and then we're going to see why they
have desirable properties like the
holographic correspondence between
entanglement and geometry reconstruction
in the entanglement wedge and
reconstruction in the causal wedge and
the key ingredient in our code
constructions is something called a
perfect tensor okay so here's what that
means let's imagine we have a pure
quantum state of two n particles two n
spins each of which is V dimensional and
I can expand that peer state in a
standard basis for the two n spins and
that defines a tensor which has two N
indices each of which takes V possible
values in the pictures that I'm going to
draw for definiteness I will be
considering six spins each of which is
two-dimensional six cubits and when I
say that the tensor is perfect what I
mean is that we can take those six
cubits in this state and partition it
into any three cubits and the
complimentary three and no matter how we
choose those three the two halves of the
system will be maximally entangled with
one another so if I trace out three of
the qubits
any three the remaining three will be in
a maximally mixed state okay it's not
obvious that such states exist but they
do in particular there are such perfect
States for six cubits okay now there are
other ways of thinking about these
perfect tensors or perfect States just
by transforming ket's into bras I can
obtain from the perfect tensor instead
of a state with six cubits a map like a
unitary transformation because of the
perfection it will always be unitary up
to normalization if I pick any three of
the qubits it defines a unitary map from
those three to the complimentary three
or I can consider it to be a mapping of
two qubits to the remaining four or one
to five and in this case since this is
unitary this will be an isometric
embedding so here for example I'm
describing a single qubit being mapped
in an inner product preserving way into
the Hilbert space of five cubits and in
fact these mappings of two qubits to
four and one qubit to five are well
known examples of quantum error
correcting codes which protect protect
against erasure of some of the qubits
now what does that mean
so when I say that we can protect
against erasure what I mean is that if
an error occurs in which some of the
qubits become inaccessible they're lost
I can nevertheless decode the qubit
that's embedded in the code space
without having to access the erase
qubits I'm able to use the information
of which qubits disappeared I know which
ones were erased and if I have that
information then I can reconstruct the
encoded system so in this case our
embedding of one qubit into five defines
a quantum error correcting code with one
encode
Cubitt embedded in a block of five which
is protected against erasure of any two
of the five cubits if any two are erased
I can still correctly decode the
protected qubit so why is that true well
we can think about it this way and see
that it follows from the fact that this
1 2 5 map is related to a perfect tensor
so suppose I consider the qubit that's
going to be embedded in the code block
to keep track of what happens to it I
imagine maximally entangling it with
some reference qubit which I denoted R
then there's a block of five cubits and
any two of those I can imagine our erase
those are the ones shown in red
but because the tensor is perfect that
means that the system consisting of R
and the two erased qubits is maximally
entangled with the 3 on erase qubit
shown in green so that means in
particular that the reference qubit is a
subsystem of these 3 on erase qubits no
matter which three we choose now the
information is redundant ly encoded in
such a way that you can take any three
out of the five cubits it doesn't matter
which three and you can recover the
encoded operation and in fact if you
want to apply analogical operation any
transformation to the encoded qubit it
suffice it is to perform an operation
that just acts on three of the qubits
and it doesn't matter which three any
three will do
so now what's a holographic code well
you can think about it this way let's
suppose I take a hyperbolic geometry and
I cover it with Pentagon's so this is a
tiling by Pentagon's that I couldn't do
on a flat plane but which I can do on a
negatively curved two-dimensional
surface where four Pentagon's all meet
at a vertex and now associate with each
one of those Pentagon's this map that
takes one qubit to a block of five the
quantum error correcting code that I
just told you about okay and so let's
imagine that we start right in the
center of the bulk so we have one qubit
that we would like to be protected and
we encoded in this block of five but
then working a radially outward from the
center I consider a sequence of maps in
which I use either my two to four high
symmetric embedding or the three to
three unitary math to take the incoming
qubits represented by the black lines
and any dangling qubits represented by
the red dots and map those two outgoing
qubits which are shown as black lines
lying further radially outward so I've
composed together many maps each of
which is either a unitary or a nice
symmetric embedding and the composition
of these asymmetries is also an isometry
and so what we wind up with is a
isometric inner product preserving map
of all of the bulk variables shown as
red dots to the uncontracted indices on
the boundary of this tensor Network so
we are to think of these uncontracted
legs on the boundary as the physical
qubits of a quantum code and all the red
dots in the bulk as the qubits of
space which is embedded in the hilbert
space of those boundary qubits and
that's what I mean by a holographic coat
now I can also consider other tilings I
can also thin out my bulk degrees of
freedom if I wish as I've done here
that's just another code in this case
I've tiled with Pentagon's and hexagons
the hexagons don't have any bulk indices
they only have the internal indices that
are contracted and associated with each
Pentagon is one logical index of the
code that corresponds to some bulk
variable okay so now we'd like to
understand this idea that operators can
be reconstructed on the boundary when
the operator is in the bulk and lies in
the causal wedge of that boundary region
so I'd like to think about it this way I
can construct what I'll call a greedy
causal wedge greedy is a word that
computer scientists use to speak of
optimization algorithms that can be
carried out one small step at a time so
imagine we start at the boundary and I
would like to push a curve on the
boundary further and further into the
bulk in a sequence of small steps and
I'll be able to make such a step if that
curve shown as the red dotted line
crosses at least three outgoing legs and
then I can move the red line one step
inward and now think of this extra
Pentagon is as a isometric map of these
two incoming indices and the bulk and
its index to these three and so as I
push further and further into the bulk
I'll obtain an isometric map from all of
the black lines which are crossed by the
red cut and all of the bulk degrees of
freedom that we swept past
as the red curve goes deeper and deeper
into the ball that's all isometrically
mapped to the ball the boundary degrees
of freedom that live in region a okay so
I keep pushing inward until I can go no
farther and that defines what I mean by
the greedy causal wedge and by
construction everything that lies within
the greedy causal wedge of a can be
reconstructed as an operator which is
supported only on a so now how should we
think about the ryu taki and Nagi
relationship between entanglement on the
boundary and geometry in the bulk well
for region a I can consider some cut
through the bulk which crosses the
contracted indices in the bulk and now
we can think of this as a sum over
tensor products of vectors in a and its
complement because we obtained a tensor
contraction associated the associating
the values of the indices along the cut
to states of a from the tensor P that we
obtained by contracting together all the
tensors to the right of the cut and we
get a map of all the degrees of freedom
along the cut labeled by I through the
tensor Q the contraction of everything
to the left hand side of the cut into
region a so this is a sum of a tensor
product of some state in region a which
is indexed by I which labels the is one
state of the indices crossing the cut
tensor dwith sorry I think that's P and
region a with Q on the complementary
region now in general these states are
not necessarily orthogonal or normal
but if this tensor P&Q if these are
isometric embeddings then these will be
mutually orthogonal states and that
means that the entanglement between a
and a complement the amount of
entanglement will just be determined by
the number of possible values for I it
will have a maximally mixed state in
some subspace whose dimension is
determined by the number of possible
values for I and now one can give a
graph theoretic argument showing that if
we have no positive curvature anywhere
in the bulk then the greedy geodesic for
region a will match the greedy geodesic
for its complement and so that means we
actually have an isometric map
associated with this tensor P and this
tensor Q and this state is a maximally
entangled state of two subsystems one
for a and one for a complement the
dimension the number of values for a is
just the number of values of the indices
I along the cut and if the spins along
the cut take V possible values that
dimension is just V raised to a power
which is the length of the cut the
number of indices that it crosses and
the entropy is just given by the log of
that number so it's proportional to the
length of the cut and that's the ring
for Utah Kannagi formula relating
entanglement to geometry so now we'd
like to understand this reconstruction
in the entanglement wedge
the case in which that can be explained
maybe most clearly it's let's imagine
that there's some procedure or some
process on the boundary that in a
independent and identically distributed
way erases boundary cubed so in other
words suppose each one of the boundary
qubits is either erased with probability
P or left on a race with probability one
minus P and then the question I'd like
to ask is whether bulk operators which
are deep inside the bulk can be
reconstructed on the UH Narae skew bits
okay but this is a case in which there's
a big difference between the causal
wedge and the entanglement wedge that I
defined earlier because if the erasure
probability is small say then the on
erase qubits will consist of segments
which there will be fluctuations but
typically they'll have a length which
goes like some something like 1 over P
if there's a probability of P for each
boundary qubit to be erased and then
there will be small gaps between those
different regions of on erased qubits
but there will be many islands of on
erased qubits with small gaps between
them and so the causal wedge of each one
of those islands will reach only a
little ways into the bulk but the
entanglement wedge will contain the
whole center of the bulk because the
shortest geodesics they connect together
all the boundary points will just span
the erase regions okay so if we erase
the boundary qubits with some
sufficiently low erasure probability
then with very high probability the
entanglement wedge is going to contain
all the points deep inside the bulk and
we'd like to see how the Balch operators
have
those points can be reconstructed on the
boundary well there's a another case
which is a little easier to think about
the case in which the our tensor network
just has the structure of a tree so let
me describe that case first
so suppose we take our encoding of one
logical protected qubit and a block of
five and then for each one of those five
we encode that in a block of five and
then for each one of those five we
encode it in a block of five and so on
just recursively encoding level by level
that's an example of what the quantum
coders call a concatenated quantum code
it's just a recursive hierarchy of codes
within codes and now we could ask if
qubits at the lowest level furthest out
along the tensor network are erased with
some iid erasure probability P can we
correct all that erasure and reconstruct
the logical information at the center
well the code the five cubed code is
correct is protected against two erasers
out of the five cubits in the block so
in order for the information to be array
so that the erasure cannot be corrected
there would have to be three or more out
of the five qubits that would be erased
so the probability that there's an
uncorrectable erasure in the block of
five if the ratio of the qubits occurs
with probability P will be of order P
cubed and with a combinatoric factor
which is just the number of ways of
choosing three qubits out of five which
is 10 okay so as we work our way inward
from the outermost leaves of this tree
to deeper and deeper levels into the
all the probability that the ratio
remains uncorrect 'add drops off very
quickly is the probability of an
uncorrected erasure at the first level
just goes like 10 P cubed but then at
the next level 10 P cubed gets cubed and
multiplied by 10 and then it gets cubed
again and multiplied by 10 and so on so
the probability of an uncorrupted
erasure if they were all together J
levels to the tree falls off doubly
exponentially with J like P over some
critical error probability to a power
which is 3 to the J and every time it
gets cubed and that critical error
probability according to this estimate
is 1 over the square root of 10 so we'd
like to do a similar type of analysis
for a holographic code but it's a little
bit trickier because the code isn't
really a tree and that means that
although the erasure process might be
iid on the boundary we can think of a
ratio or different qubits as being
independent that will no longer be true
as we move in from the boundary then we
start to get correlated erase your
errors because a single one of the
blocks at you know level J can feed into
two blocks at level J plus 1 but this
isn't really as bad as it might seem
because of the hyperbolic geometry that
prevents the correlations in the noise
from propagating outward very much so at
each level as we go deeper and deeper
into the bulk we really only have to
worry about correlated errors between
neighboring qubits and that makes it
possible to analyze the problem and show
that once again the probability of an
uncorrupted erasure error once we reach
the center of the bulk will become
ee exponentially small in the number of
layers in the tensor network although
now the power that appears here is a
little bit different involves the golden
ratio and this analytic estimate gives
us a critical value for the racial
problem erasure probability which is
about 0.08 but if we actually do numerix
to see how things go in a case like this
where to understand what happens deep in
the bulk I just consider the code with
one protected qubit in the center and
all the other indices contracted then
the threshold value of the erasure
probability is appears to be one-half
and so that means that if I want to be
able to reconstruct a bulk operator on
some subset of the boundary and that
subset is a randomly chosen subset that
contains at least half of all the qubits
on the boundary then with very high
probability the reconstruction will be
possible okay so the bulk degrees of
freedom are very robust against erasure
of the boundary and correspondingly we
can reconstruct the operators which are
deep inside the entanglement which well
because I wanted to show you that it is
possible to give an analytic argument
that there is a threshold and that means
that once the erasure probability is
less than point 83 then we're guaranteed
analytically to be able to reconstruct
the operators deep inside but our you
know our analytic estimate is much too
pessimistic and the actual threshold is
as high as it could possibly be it's 1/2
it couldn't be higher because if we
could correct a ratio or more than half
the qubits then that would violate the
no-cloning theorem because I could
divide the
qubits into two sets and if I could
correct erasure and both of them then I
would be able to clone so as we've seen
there's something very robust about this
relationship between the bulk and
degrees of freedom and the boundary
degrees of freedom there's something
kind of pleasing about that that if we
want to think of the geometry as being
an emergent property of the entanglement
on the bulk we would like the properties
of the geometry to not be so sensitive
to the exact state on the boundary and
once we get deep in bulk the details of
what's going on in the boundary become
not so important for doing the
reconstruction now I haven't talked
about black holes but remember I also
had mentioned that we don't really have
the complete dictionary here because
we're only describing some code subspace
of the boundary Hilbert space well why
is that
most of the states on the boundary are
very high energy states what do they
correspond to in the bulk large black
holes the large black holes have many
microscopic degrees of freedom and if
there's an exact match between the
Hilbert space of the bulk and the
Hilbert space of the boundary then
actually most of the states in the bulk
or most of the states in the boundary
should correspond to black holes in the
bulk so we really want a complete
correspondence then we have to include
the black holes and that you haven't
been part of our discussion so far
because our code space has only
attempted to describe logical operations
acting on the low energy states on the
boundary so one way of picturing the
black holes is we can imagine cutting a
hole in the tensor network and that will
leave additional uncontracted indices in
the bulk those correspond to the black
hole microstates and now what our
isometric embedding does is it Maps all
of the black hole microstates and the
bulk degrees of freedom out
side the black hole to the boundary
hilbert space
so that's the story of holographic
quantum codes it is not the full story
of holography it's really my attempt to
understand holography it's always seems
so mysterious that somehow there could
be this exact correspondence between two
different descriptions of the same
physics but it smelled like quantum
error correction because of the feature
that the bulk observables deep inside
the bulb correspond to very non-local
operators on the boundary just the kind
of encoding that is well protected if
the environment is looking at the system
locally it can't see that bulk
information and so in this construction
we tried to make that idea more precise
and concrete it illustrates how quantum
error correction can resolve this causal
wedge puzzle that is that we can
reconstruct the same boundary operator
in multiple ways because the different
reconstructions although physically
different on the boundary act in the
code space on the same way and we can
see how they were utaki and nagi
relationship between entanglement and
bulk geometry is realized in this
concrete setting there's a lot of
flexibility in how we do the
construction for ease of drawing I've
stuck with a two-dimensional rendering
of the bulk space we can consider tiling
in higher dimensions by polyhedra and
again use a perfect tensor construction
to get similar results how we can choose
different types of tilings and as I
mentioned in passing we can if we want
to describe lower dimension code
subspaces or a thinned out version of
the observables in the bulk we can just
choose the tiling appropriately in order
to do so there's a lot missing from this
descript description first of all it's
just kinematic it's only attempting to
understand the relationship between the
bulk and the boundary at some fixed time
okay it will be much more interesting to
talk about dynamics to consider how our
code space evolves according to some
local Hamiltonian acting on the boundary
hilbert space and that's something we're
still thinking about and it hasn't
helped us to understand the locality and
the bulk on distances that are small
compared to the ad S curvature because
we've only associated a degree of
freedom with each one of our polygons
which has a size which is comparable to
the curvature radius so as I said at the
end of my talk last time I think these
connections between quantum information
and quantum gravity are very intriguing
they're giving us new ways to think
about some very hard problems and I
think that's going to lead to further
progress but we're still in the early
stages of exploring these connections
just as as I've said we're just at the
early stages of the exploration of
quantum information science and we have
a lot to look forward to as we develop
the experimental tools to study highly
entangled systems and new ways and I
think the most exciting to me message
from this connection between quantum
entanglement and quantum geometry is
that potentially it makes quantum
gravity a subject that can be studied
experimentally in tabletop experiments
because what we would like to understand
better is what types of highly entangled
systems have some kind of holographic
dual description we know some examples
of that but I think it's a much more
generic phenomenon and we haven't yet
understood exactly what the connections
are between complexity of a quantum
system and an emergent geometry we
haven't understood it very well because
it's very difficult it involves
understanding properties of highly
entangled systems that we can simulate
very well and that we don't have the
theoretical tools to study in sufficient
depth so I'm hopeful that people at the
Yale quantum Institute someday we'll be
doing experiments which will give us
insights that we couldn't have derived
in other ways from laboratory
experiments so thanks it's been exciting
to be here at Yale the last few days and
I appreciate everyone's hospitality and
generosity and thanks for listening to
all my talks
very much time for today's talking for a
really great series and just to clarify
would be great if we would be able to do
something with a quantum computer that
would contribute to black holes but
we're not gonna actually build a black
hole here so the question was as a
practical matter is it possible to turn
erase your errors into other types well
I guess let me answer a slightly
different question than the one you
asked so we could ask suppose we have a
code which protects well against erasure
what can we say about how well that code
will protect against more general types
of errors and in fact if we can correct
against in a block of n qubits if we can
correct against 2k erasure errors and by
that I mean we know which of the two K
qubits out of the end have been damaged
and we can use that information to
recover then that same code can be used
to correct against cares in the block
when the cares occur on unknown qubits
so the codes that correct against
erasure can also be used to correct
against more general errors but the air
correcting power is reduced if we don't
know which are the qubits that are
damaged
the size of the boundary and physical
given to the size of the circle to the
size and physical well remember it's a
hyperbolic geometry so sorry the
question was it seems that we have
embedded the bulk in the boundary but
shouldn't the boundary be smaller than
the bulk so in fact in this hyperbolic
setting the boundary should not be
smaller than the ball kids part of the
reason that our understanding of
holography
is a most complete in the case of
anti-de sitter space so we can have an
exact correspondence between states
living on the boundary and States living
in the bulk because in a hyperbolic
geometry
you know the boundary and the bulk
actually have if you discretize them or
tile them they actually have comparable
cardinality Elementary equations the
same time how about the distinguish but
from the boundary if you have a discrete
system right so you're talking about
some kind of a network basically Ryan's
sites these are a personal way to
distinguish about from boundary well so
you mean if I if I just gave you the
graph of the tensor network how would
you know well in the case of of this
construction I think there is you know
an unambiguous unambiguous way of doing
that because of the structure of the
geometry that we tie
in general of course it would not be
easy the thing to do if I just gave you
a graph it would be rather arbitrary to
say what was the boundary and what is
the bulk but you know if you like
there's a graph and I am going to use
that graph to describe a relationship
between two Hilbert spaces and I will by
Fiat say I'm interested in these as the
boundary qubits and regard those as
physical and the others as logical so
but this was a particularly natural way
of choosing the graph to correspond to
ad s space well well it has Farrar and
for our discussion it was important that
when we when we constructed this this
isometric embedding the way I described
it when I went too far I guess when we
started in the middle and then composed
isometry z-- to filled up big isometry
in each step I needed to have a number
of incoming legs which was at most three
and so for each one of the Pentagon's
including the dangling index in the bulk
I had at most two indices which were
contracted with Pentagon's which were
deeper in the ball and so the tensor
contraction defied defines a composition
of maps each of which take two or three
qubits to either four or three and so
each one is either a unitary or an
embedding and the fact that the graph
had that structure
was well it would not have had that
structure if there had been a bubble of
positive curvature somewhere in the bulk
a smaller portion of the boundary is
that does that have any implications on
their robustness
grass but that's sort of in a different
way so yeah I guess your your noting
that you know we don't have a you know a
complete translational symmetry or if I
rotate the graph that I can do there are
discrete rotations that I have to make
you know because there's a big
difference between this gap here and
these guys being close together the
graph doesn't look like it's as
symmetrical as one would as one might
like is that what you meant
and this this causal slice and looked
like that the information on when cubed
is written on this the smaller portion
with the oh I see what you're saying
yeah so you're saying that if I consider
say a bulk degree of freedom which is
close to the boundary it is not as well
protected against a ratio as bulk
variables that are deep inside and that
that's correct so that's in fact why in
my discussion of the entanglement wedge
I emphasize reconstruction of the
operators that are very deep inside the
ones that are deep inside are very well
protected the ones that are very close
to the boundary are much easier to
damage because you need to erase only a
smaller hunk of the boundary in an ATS
space-time where where's the well I
didn't necessarily mean that the eraser
should be regarded as a physical process
I was thinking about erasure as a way of
keeping track of the ways in which bulk
operators could be reconstructed on the
boundary so when I spoke of a ratio I
meant I can consider some set of on
erase qubits and ask whether a certain
bulk operator can be reconstructed with
support only on those on erased qubits
and if it can be then you know I say
that that bulk operator corresponds to
an operator that is supported only on
that on the race set